hello and welcome to swipe coming up the
electrifying world of racing we take a
closer look at formula e putting the
science into sport the human performance
lab that should help improve on athletes
the game in Spain gran turismo is create
our heads to and Alethea to launch the
SEC than this series and its trying to
fill your stocking you review a few of
the main games that are fighting out for
sales this Christmas it was once
mockingly described as the milk float
challenge but no the world of motorsport
and technology is revving up or should
that be charging up for the start of
formula e the FAA's new electric car
championship sees ten cities turned into
racetracks next year starting in Beijing
and ending here in London all ten team
sports have now been filled but will
fans get behind the sports and will it
achieve its goal of boosting electric
car sales skies your tiny reports it
looks like Formula One but have a listen
to this
formula e is the FIA s brand new
all-electric championship a greener
quieter and more sustainable form of
motor racing and it's not just the cars
that are different this Championships
been designed for the digital age
computer gamers can play live in real
time as the races unfold and fans can
give their favorite drivers a speed
boost by voting for them on a smartphone
you will have a button in the in the
steering wheel that gives you an extra
boost of power and drivers will get it
through their fans so the fans will vote
and through social media they will get
this extra boost so they can never take
the car in front of them all of this is
Alejandro Agag zai dear the Spanish f1
TV rights owner wants to improve the
image and innovation of electric cars
but since launching formula e has
suffered its own image problem being
dubbed the milk float challenge by
skeptics now that's starting to change
all 10 team spots have now been filled
with four-time f1 champion Alain Prost
starting a team and the two final spots
taken by a mystery Hollywood a-lister
and former f1 team owner sir richard
branson there's obviously very
compelling environmental reasons why
this is better than some other sports
but just be frank we loved Formula One
and we think that we're going to love
formally no one knows because it's just
about to start electric car makers like
Tesla who opened up shop in Britain last
month hope the championship will boost
interest figure showy car sales are at a
record high in Britain but take up is
slow and manufacturers say motorists are
put off by a lack of infrastructure
10,000 charge points have been installed
by the government but companies like
tesla and nissan are beginning to
install their own charging areas to get
things moving themselves Alejandro
admits that battery power will also be
an issue for Formula e as drivers will
need to switch cars halfway through the
race to keep going to seat drivers
jumping from one car to another is going
to add a completely new element but it's
hoped as the teams compete and the sport
evolves electric car technology will
improve with it and it might even get
some petrol heads turning to Joe tidy
Sky News you're watching swype coming up
gran turismo heads to spin to show off
about its sixth incarnation but for
rest in professional sports nothing is
left to chance these days to be
physically and mentally ready to compete
the modern-day athlete has to have every
aspect of the performance analyzed we
got a brief glimpse into how this tech
heavy world works at GlaxoSmithKline's
human performance lab this week when Sky
Sports Pete graves went along yes i'm
here outside the GSK human performance
labs very exciting because cameras have
never been allowed inside here before so
let's not have a look what's inside so
we're now making our way into the lab
and this set is a world-leading science
and research facility okay well now
we're inside the lab and there's so much
to see and walking now on a
state-of-the-art 4g astroturf this is so
athletes can train on and the equivalent
of grass and that surfaces that they'll
be playing on in their sport and up here
on the wall and the six pillars of what
this performance lab is all about
strength stamina cognition hydration
metabolism and recovery it's great to
have that kind of scientific approach
behind the game i think it's becoming a
lot more scientific disease i mean
everyone sees kind of countess in the
bachelor share which are GPS units
people where heart rate monitors so here
it's about kind of continue to improve
whether it's with nutrition and staff
and seeing what the body actually needs
whether it's more calories less quoting
more protein less carbs stop like this
and being able to make sure you keep on
improving so this is the cognition lab
it's where they deal with brain training
so sportsmen reaction times decision
making what they say is in here they're
using this state-of-the-art equipment to
train everything above the neck
in there is the hydro lab and what they
do here is they look at the effects that
water can have on muscle pain and
recovery all in here is the physiology
lab and it's where the really scientific
stuff happens and they take a detailed
look at athletes performance we can
understand the limits of human function
and through that we actually learn a
great deal about the way in which the
body works and unfortunately for us
we're looking at that point and
cognitively so in terms of brain
function and if we can understand these
mechanisms so we can bring it back to
the man on the street well the last bit
we want to show you is here and this is
where they test the athletes strength
and performance I might just look like a
normal gym here but it isn't over here
they've got some really sophisticated
scientific equipment which allows the
scientists here and to work on the link
between diet muscle mass and performance
you're watching swype coming up the
arrests made over alleged Bitcoin scams
in Germany and China but first gran
turismo is creator Kazunori Yamauchi
it's pretty much gaming gods to fans of
the franchise so what better way to
celebrate his legacy the naming a street
after him and not just any street Rhonda
in Spain will feature in the 6th edition
of the game so in a special two-day
event the game went to Spain skies kitty
Spencer put on her open back velcro
fastened leather driving gloves and sent
us this report the puente nuevo bridge
is an impressive piece of architecture
which divides the city of rhonda but who
needs to travel to southern Spain when
the virtual version looks like this for
the last 15 years gran turismo has set
the standard for the racing genre now in
its sixth incarnation its creator is
promising an experience that's even
closer to the real thing wherever
kazunori yamauchi goes there's no
shortage of fans and in ronda he
received a rock star like reception in
recognition of the cultural impact of
computer games the city has afforded him
with the same honor they gave Ernest
Hemingway and Orson Welles by naming a
street after him I'm a mother [ __ ] got
I think if by making gran turismo I'm
receiving this honor today it might mean
that the makers of video games have
reached a point where they're equal to
authors actors even the politicians in
the world and that really makes me happy
to be doing what I've been doing all
these years today's biggest brands jump
at the chance to be included in Gran
Turismo it's one of Sony's most popular
franchises selling over 70 million
copies around the world the GT Academy
has also helped turn several gamers into
Pro drivers so just what is it about the
driving simulator that's proven so
popular the concept is very simple it's
to convey the beauty of the cars the
beauty of the environment the speed the
light the atmosphere and the feel Rhonda
not only features in the game's photo
mode but it's also a new
course maker location cause for
celebration for the 36,000 people who
live here ya know your master feel a sin
or whatever yeah everyone that comes to
Rhonda falls in love with the city so
we're very grateful we're gaming has led
the way the movie world looks set to
follow sony has confirmed a film based
on Gran Turismo is currently in
development Testament perhaps of how the
rest of the entertainment industry is
now playing catch up with the gaming
world Keita Spencer Sky News you
watching swipe coming up dust off your
dance moves we're looking at the games
which are set to be big sellers this
Christmas but first he has a run top of
anything you might have missed over the
last few days police have picked up five
people in connection with bitcoins camps
in Germany two suspected fraudsters were
arrested in connection with an
investigation which find a botnet being
used to secretly generate the virtual
currency by RIT great mining on other
people's pcs three people were also
detained in China after investors were
cut off from the funds when a trading
platform was shut down without warning
an American hacker claims he can control
other people's jaunts whilst they're
still in the air with a radio-controlled
quadcopter a Raspberry Pi and two
transmitters the sky jack system claims
to be able to hijack nearby devices Samy
Kamkar is a bit of an expert at these
things back in 2005 he managed to hack
into myspace and shut it down as soon as
it finds any other drones it hacks into
that drones wireless network disconnects
the owner and then takes over that drone
so my drone is flying around finds
drones takes them over and then begins
controlling them under my command
sticking with Jones known and is this
the future of parcel delivery are merely
a clever PR stunt amazon has announced
it hopes to use drones to eventually
deliver parcels to your door there are a
few caveats though you have to live
within 10 miles of one of their
fulfillment centers and not be ordering
something huge see for example amazon
head honcho Jeff Bezos his yacht now
brace yourself for some hardcore nerdy
news USB cables that annoying right
especially when you try to put them in
the wrong way
well fear not developers have announced
a new version of the connector plug that
will be reversible don't get too excited
though they're not likely to come to
market until 2016 so who do you reckon
would be the most searched-for person on
the internet in the UK well for me it
would have to be myself but no according
to search engine Bing the most searched
for celebrity is Justin Bieber sometimes
I despair interestingly the other nine
in the top 10 were all women including
the likes of Kim Kardashian Rihanna and
Selena Gomez I might just have had
something to do with that rev up your
engine prepare for the Pirates and get
ready to strut your stuff Christmas is
getting closer and there's going to be a
gaming battle to be a stocking best
seller so we've drafted in games expert
come early to talk us through the games
he thinks will come out on top yeah I've
been in this game for a lot of years I
got out alive Don theft auto 5 is the
game that really needs no introduction
and yeah it came out in September but
there's been a lot of updates since then
and that makes it really worth
revisiting so the main update since then
is the beach bum content pack so it
basically enables you to take on either
a campervan or June buggy and just
explore this fictionalized version of
Los Angeles on top of that there's also
the fact that the online component which
is the multiplayer part of the game
didn't really work when it came out in
September there were a lot of issues now
ever that's been fixed and the potential
for where the game and the series are
going to go in future is huge so we
don't know if it's going to go on
next-gen consoles just yet but if for
any reason you missed it on current-gen
consoles now's the time to rectify that
and it's easily the best value game you
can get this way
assassins before Black Flag is the
latest entry in the very popular
Assassin's Creed franchise you may have
heard of the franchise before casters an
assassin this time around it takes place
in the golden age of pirates you taught
me how to live in liberty and die
defiant you're in the Caribbean your
scone of the waves so whether you want
to kind of be creeping through jungles
or searching ruins or you know just
harpooning whales on the open waves it's
all doable and soon as the weather is
about to get bit colder nice bit of
escapism setting the Caribbean which we
like but you know it's a fantastic game
and you shouldn't be put off by the fact
at the fourth entry in the franchise
because really you don't need to played
any of the previous games it seems very
little knowledge and it's great fun lots
to do huge open world hours of
entertainment just dance 2014 may seem a
bit frivolous but the fact the matter is
it's the latest entry in the best Island
dance franchise of all time Christmas is
all about for vallecito if you're
looking for a game to crack out on
Boxing Day and play with the entire
family look no further additionally this
is the first version of the game to be
available on next-gen console so it
takes a bunch of all the new technology
of the xbox one and and in particular
the xbox one's new Kinect picked up
really well and their songs from sigh
Lady Gaga ever like Bob Marley so you
should be able to find something for
everyone to have have a little dance t
need for speed rivals is actually a very
fortunate position because driveclub and
the crew we've both been delayed to 2014
which means it's actually the only
arcade racer available for next-gen
consoles right now the things I've done
a better person would feel bad it's
incredibly exciting this time around you
get to play as either a cop or racer and
pick your side it's an open world so you
get to drive around the city and it
blurs the lines between single and
multiplayer so your friends can just pop
up in your city and you know you can
start races with them whenever whenever
you fancy so it's very exciting game and
if you're looking for a racing fix on
the next gen consoles pretty much all
you've got for the foreseeable future
that's your lot for this week remember
you can catch up with the breaking tech
stories all week on Sky News for iPad or
smartphone apps and sky news com we'll
see you next time
you